what are the Hunger Games for so one
thing you probably know really well
about the world of The Hunger Games is
that unless it's a quarter quill the
rules are simple only children between
the ages of 12 and 18 can compete but
casting for The Ballad of songbirds and
snakes wasn't even close to as strict
one of these teenagers is bridging on
30. honestly these age gaps are gonna
surprise you
from District 12 Lucy gray Baird Lucy
graybeard is supposed to be 16 and
during filming after Rachel Ziegler was
already 21. that's a five-year
difference Rachel never had to even
audition for the role the director of
the original trilogy Francis Lawrence
already knew he wanted her to play Lucy
but she initially turned it down saying
I wanted to disappear because she was
away from everybody that she knew and
loved so she said no however she did
have something else in the pipeline that
fell through so she put her name back
into the mix after they already
auditioned I feel really bad for any of
the girls who had now despite the age
Gap she does have a more Charming
demeanor that Francis describes as the
anti-catness it's a demeanor that makes
her seem a bit younger than Jennifer
Lawrence portraying Katniss there's a
natural goodness built into us all even
if there was only a four-year gap
between J law and the girl on fire but
they'd still be friends I have not
talked to Jennifer Lawrence but if she
wants to call me can we can hang out
anytime time it's a new Curry Lane this
is one we haven't seen before we get
some pretty baby face mentors in The
Ballad of songbirds and snakes which is
in stark contrast to Haymitch from the
original trilogy Cory Elena snow is 18
years old in the prequel it's uh an
originated kind of young version of him
but the actor playing him Tom Blythe
seven years old at the time the time
filming
you but that wise demeanor doesn't
scream 18 to me the fans have a lot of
expectations of what they want to see
and I hope I honor that and speaking
about the books Tom says although
they're young adults entertainment
they're also there are layers to it now
we'll swing back around to snow in a
minute but first euphoria's Hunter
Schaefer is playing the role of 21 year
old Tiger snow coriolanus's cousin in
the prequel Hunter was 23 during filming
that's just a two-year age gap between
actor and character not so bad but where
things get mind-blowing is that Eugenie
Bondurant played the role in Mockingjay
in 2013 and she would have been in her
early 50s laying an 86 year old that's a
discrepancy of over 30 years but hey
it's probably pretty safe to assume the
capital's big on plastic surgery
everybody in the cast is wonderful
including Josh Andre Rivera District 2
Mentor so Janus Clint is also around 18
years old during the 10th annual Hunger
Games he's played by 26 year old Josh
who's just a few months younger than Tom
now that's a gap of eight years between
Josh and his character now okay we know
that one should never say a lady's age
however Viola Davis was cast
appropriately finally we found one Dr
volum is supposed to be in her 50s and
Viola hits it out of the ballpark being
just 56 at the start of filming however
with the level of unhinged they're
portraying her as it feels like it's
adding a few good years hey maybe it's
just stress I'm trying to scare the
Jesus out of these kids and I don't I
don't know if it's gonna work Jason
Schwartzman plays Lucky flickerman in
The Ballad of songbirds and snakes and
for those of you who maybe saw the movie
trailer and grew concerned no lucky is
not the same guy from the 74th Hunger
Games that's Caesar flickerman lucky is
probably Caesar's dad but we don't have
proof but we can make an educated nefo
baby guest given the name similar looks
and job title after I get over that
quick thing of wow really then I totally
can see it at it does make sense now the
fun continues as Jason got to learn
magic for the role Jason was 41 when
they started filming now we don't know
how old his character is but we do have
more info on Caesar which should give us
insight into lucky Stanley Tucci was 50
during the filming of The Hunger Games
but his character Caesar flickerman was
supposed to be in his 70s or 80s Stanley
Tucci and Caesar have an incredible age
gap of between 20 and 39 years now to
get back to figuring out Lucky's age
Caesar would have had to have been at
least six and could have been as old as
25 during the events of the ballad of
songbirds and snakes but let's assume
Caesar's middle of the range and was
about 16 years old during the 10th
Hunger Games Jason Schwartzman was
perfectly cast at 41 years old being
about 25 when he had his son Caesar now
of course this all relies on the theory
that they are in fact father and son so
there's not a whole lot of info about
Nick Benson and his portrayal of the
District 12 mail tribute Jessup Diggs
yet but I thought it was worth
mentioning that there's an age gap of 10
years between Jessup and Nick that's
right Nick was 28 when they filmed and
his character is only supposed to be 18.
let's compare that to The District 12
male tribute from the 74th Hunger Games
16 year old Peta was portrayed by 18
year old Josh Hutcherson an age gap of
just two years not many of our
characters from the original trilogy
were even born by the 10th Hunger Games
but our Central character the reason for
the prequel existing is Cory Elena snow
originally played by Donald Sutherland
he was 75 when he started filming for
The Hunger Games in 2011. snow had to be
82 around the time of the 74th Hunger
Games and surprisingly there was
actually less of an age gap between
Donald and snow than there is between
Tom and snow seven years versus nine
even Liam Hemsworth was just 21 playing
an 18 year old in the OD Trilogy while I
am obsessed with everything I've seen so
far for The Ballad of songbirds and
snakes I can't help but wonder why the
teenagers in the prequel are trade by
considerably older actors the fact is
you can never please everyone were you
surprised by some other age differences
let me know in the comments